hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
sanna Monica we're gonna watch this
video called Shia LaBeouf live by Rob
Cantor turn in your phone off I don't
ever want the text message from your
boyfriend coming in oh we are filming
he's tired with the treated well now mix
the house but okay what an exciting
story yeah
the game ends okay I've heard about this
you're walking in the woods there's no
one around and your phone is dead oh my
god at the corner of your eye you
spotted it
he's following you about 30 feet back he
gets down on all fours and breaks into a
sprint he's gaining on you Shia LaBeouf
that's it you're looking for your car
but you're all turned around he's almost
upon you now and you can see this one of
the space Mike got this blood everywhere
now it's dark and you seem to have lost
it but you're hopelessly lost yourself
you're branded with a murderer you creep
silently through the underbrush aha
in the distance a small cottage with a
lighter hope you move stealthily toward
it
what a egg ah it's caught in a bear trap
but he doesn't
you're speaking up your night
crackling superstar Shia LaBeouf
everybody say
into the dark woods blood oozing from
your stump leg you beat Shia LaBeouf he
is a dead there's a gun to your head
that you can do jujitsu
this is like break
he's gonna get
you can shopping
his head topples to the floor
expressionless you fall to your knees
and catch your breath
you're finally safe yes oh my god
Shia LaBeouf has just earned so many
cool points dude like I used to love him
then I was kind of iffy about him now
he's just like one of the coolest dudes
the world to me yeah could you know what
that's from what there wasn't there was
a viral video like a stupid like cartoon
that someone made called actual cannibal
Shia LaBeouf or it's just like it's
really bad like mspaint like cartoon and
my killing people and they just parodied
that and the best freaking oh no that
was also kind of epic like I want that
on my iPod yeah I do
I would love watching that like seeing a
live seems like this is actually a
pretty cool show it's funny but it's
pretty cool and it does hook you in just
it brings the viral videos to a whole
new level
oh yeah because a lot of work went into
that that was like crazy they had a
whole orchestra going on yeah Shia
LaBeouf that was I was not expecting
that until they said I turned the camera
mic photography is mind blowing like
that video of Will Ferrell playing drums
next to the drummer Chad Smith Red Hot
Chili Peppers yeah and that's like up
there that was fantastic
and I loved that Shia LaBeouf is at the
end thank you guys for telling it
actually a good video not like one's
weird ones right questions yeah and
exactly how violent and disgusting
sexually everything is let it be maybe
forget product placement from cocoliche
it my love yes if you to channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and sally
has a channel to you I know you want to
subscribe for that now so go ahead and
check out her channel as for shoutouts I
am caught up on shout outs say something
interesting at facebook.com slash the
real rejection take care now bye babe